know what you want the key to having
success in business and in life is to
know what you want you have to know what
you want if you want to get it I went
shopping for a snowboarding jacket
recently picked up snowboarding last
year is coming up on winter again and
I'm excited to go snowboarding and I
needed a real snowboarding jacket this
time so I went to my local store I don't
know anything about snowboarding jackets
nothing I use like a regular winter
jacket last year and it was terrible so
time to get the real equipment I walk in
and talk to a salesman and he starts
showing me around he's asked me the
typical questions what's your budget
what's your style I got no idea
but as we start going through it I can
tell them what I like and what I don't
like okay I could tell that most of the
jackets I don't like the things that
come up and like hide your face up to
here I don't like the super poufy
jackets I don't like the pockets that
that stick out I want it to be slim I
wanted to look sexy that's the kind of
style that I want and I discovered that
as I was going through the process and I
told them no no no no no no no I was
trying on tons of different jackets and
I told them I'm sorry I'm being I'm
being like a really hard customer for
you and he said no you're a great
customer because most people come in to
me and they have no idea what they want
and they can't articulate what they need
so I can't help them at the end of my
experience with him I knew exactly what
I needed
in a snowboarding jacket now
unfortunately he didn't have what I
wanted in stock but we could quickly get
to that decision whether he could help
me or not and where I had to go to get
what I needed if you want to have
success in your business and in your
life you have to know what you want you
have to know what feels right what
you're going after because if you know
that you can go and achieve it but if
you're like I guess most customers for
this guy who walk in and they're not
sure they're wandering around and
they're wasting their time then you're
never gonna get what you wanted in life
because you have no idea what it is so
figure out what you want and then set a
plan in motion that go out and achieve
it believe for those of you watching
like the video please give it a thumbs
up
and I'd love to hear where you have to
think do you know what you want write
down below what you want I want to see
it if you have a question leave it below
to I'll make your video response you
guys Rock thank you so much I'll see you
soon